continuity and Avengers endgame could
get confusing even if you were in charge
of decorating sets a sharp-eyed fan is
pointed out an inconsistency when the
Avengers travel back to 2012 one you're
only likely to notice if you have every
detail of the Avengers committed to
memory in case you need a quick
refresher and game ii AXYZ different
teams of Avengers traveling to different
periods in the past in an attempt to
snatch all six Infinity stones before
the mad Titan Thanos can get his hands
on them Tony Stark Steve Rogers Scott
Lang and Bruce Banner are tasked with
returning to 2012 in the Battle of New
York where they no three can be found
the time stone the mine stone and the
space stone Banner is able to convince
the ancient one to pony up the time
stone but grabbing the other two proves
to be a great deal trickier after a
brawl in stark tower Loki is initially
secured and both the space stone and the
mine stone is in the custody of the
Avengers but as they and a bunch of
shield agents start heading down the
elevator to drop Loki off to the
authorities it becomes apparent that one
of the heroes will have to take the
stairs what do you think maximum
occupancy has been reached just yes stop
stop
what we'd like to call your attention to
is the interior of that elevator
because when the time-traveling Avengers
take a ride in it it looks a little bit
different than it did the first time we
saw it here's the stark tower elevator
as we saw it's in 2012's The Avengers
meanwhile here's the same elevator with
all of our heroes aboard and Avengers
end game we never realized that one of
the lesser-known effects of time travel
involves slight changes to the decor of
your target destination you'll notice
that the rest of the set dressing is
spot-on the interior of the elevator
though is plainly not even in the
ballpark we know what you're thinking
the hard-working folks behind Avengers
endgame set design deserve a break here
after all they were tasked not only with
giving a distinct look and feel to a
film that would become the biggest of
all time but also with painstakingly
replicating sets from previous movies
ones which they almost certainly didn't
even work on how can they possibly have
been expected to nail every last little
detail well realistically they couldn't
have but there's a flipside to that
argument obviously the Avengers was used
as a reference when staging the scene if
it hadn't been the rest of the decor in
the shot wouldn't have matched up it's
highly unlikely that that table those
lamps in that sculpture had been sitting
in a closet somewhere on Disney's lot
since the Avengers completed filming
just waiting to be dragged out and used
in another scene know those props almost
certainly had to be recreated for
endgame and if that detail of the old
start our set was subject to scrutiny
when the flicks crew was building the
sets for the Battle of New York scenes
than all of them were so what's up with
the elevator did they think nobody would
ever notice thought we wouldn't notice
but we did we'd like to propose an
in-universe explanation what if the
Avengers didn't travel back to their
Battle of New York but an ever so
slightly different alternate Battle of
New York it could even be that the
aesthetic of Tony Stark's elevator was
literally the only difference between
the two timelines we like this
explanation because maintaining
continuity with the entire rest of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe on endgame
must have been the ultimate logistical
nightmare it definitely couldn't have
been a snap to bring everything back
from previous films there are probably a
million other tiny errors like this just
waiting to be discovered and we just
explained every last one of them in one
fell swoop check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]